alright guys here with with Michael from
a Genesis trading how are you doing
today
not too bad how are you awesome so we
got a lot of comfort today but uh before
we kind of dive in I think probably lots
of people know about Genesis and some
stuff you guys do but might not know as
much about you personally so maybe we
could just start with kind of your
background and then we can get into how
you first discovered crypto sure so I am
a reformed investment banker right out
of college I did a seven and a half
years at Citi in the financial
institutions group sort of covering
finance companies banks and and and
credit card companies and then I left
city in 2008 and that's when I met Barry
Barry Silbert the the founder and CEO of
digital currency group was running a
company called second market at the time
and this is right at kind of the onset
of the financial crisis and and a lot of
financial assets were becoming more and
more illiquid and so I joined up with
him in the fall of eight and started
getting involved in the sort of the
illiquid asset backed securities and
sort of the the toxic assets that came
about as a result of the financial
crisis and then uh one thing clear led
to another second market got involved in
crypto in twenty late-2012
as sort of when we really started to
study this space and we open up our
trading desk in 2013
how did that'll get started that was all
Barry Barry I think personally
discovered Bitcoin in 2011 spent about
six months sort of being a non-believer
to skeptic to believer to evangelist he
can kind of complete the whole cycle in
2012 and then he wouldn't stop talking
about it in the office
and so we said all right Barry what's
what's a bit quiet let's kind of chat
about it and at the time we were making
a market and all kinds of funky illiquid
esoteric off the run financial assets
and he said you know what it coins
another one
it raised like a lot of the other things
we were trading at the time and so I
said okay let's let's do this and this
was March 2013 so
March 2013 you guys kind of get the
confidence okay let's jump in start
making a market with Bitcoin right what
was kind of at that time that concerns
that people are voicing even though you
guys are going to do it it's a it's a
few things one we were starting from
scratch the one thing we did have was
Barry's rolodex he had made a lot of
contacts early on so he knew really a
lot of the early adopters but we really
didn't have worthy investors was sort of
the buy-side demand so you had the guys
that own Bitcoin for like a dollar right
but you didn't have was kind of the
traditional institutional capital ready
to kind of step up and be the the other
side of the market so one kind of
establishing a rolodex ourselves of the
buy side guys secondly I think there was
a lot of questions around money
laundering AML kyc second market is a
broker dealer so we've always have sort
of had the SEC and FINRA overseeing all
of our AML kyc compliance but bitcoins
just another animal right fixed-income
compliance is entirely different than
sort of banking compliance and so there
was a lot we had to kind of get
comfortable ourselves as well as our
regulators to prove to them that we knew
what we were doing and thirdly I think a
lot of the infrastructure that exists
today simply obviously weren't there
right even simple things like trying to
like do you know like the Bloomberg
equivalent and having a trading terminal
kind of getting up and going simple
things like you know how do we set up
wallets
you know the Zappos and the bit goes of
the world that are sort of dominant
today really we're just kind of getting
started back then and so trying to
figure out how to properly store your
bitcoins those types of things things
you'd never had to worry about in the
securities world
we're big issues and so I think those
were some of the biggest things it's
interesting because as much as things
have changed they've kind of stayed the
same right there's still conversation
around you know compliance anti money
laundering
you know kyc there's conversation around
infrastructure for you know
institutional type
stirrers is it high-quality enough how
do they use this stuff and so it feels
like we just have moved kind of you know
that conversation down the road and kind
of up to the institutional level now but
but really what you're describing is it
wasn't even there for retail right 2:13
we used to have individuals show up at
our office with a suitcase full of cash
wanting to buy Bitcoin that would
provide no driver's license no
identification but here's my proof of
funds and they'll open up their
briefcase that world obviously that was
2013 we don't have that issue anymore
and so a lot of the issues that we're
trying to tackle right now are actually
much higher quality problems than we
were trying to solve back in 2013
but you know and and I would argue that
we've come so far from from where we are
but the market really expects how kind
of the equities world works and how the
commodities world works and but that
took like decades of evolution for to
kind of get to today crypto this is
really can been mainstream for like a
couple of years and I'd argue that
having futures products on the CME and
the CBOE that was unthinkable back then
and so I think about all the progress
we've made rather than everything that's
still missing absolutely it was that's
an interesting anecdote right so people
are showing up to the office with you
know suitcases of cash and just let me
buy a Bitcoin what's their psychology or
what's driving them to do that they
couldn't there was no exchange
infrastructure that's for them to use
they didn't trust the exchanges they're
doing nefarious activity kind of why are
they walking in with you know cash
trying to buy Bitcoin um I would argue
that it's probably a combination of both
so when we first started there were
really like two exchanges you had its
stamp that was still in Slovenia he had
mount docks at a Tokyo and if you really
wanted to buy a bunch of Bitcoin you
were wiring money to a foreign country
and just keeping your fingers crossed
that the funds kind of get there right
and so here we were where we were we had
an office you could actually walk into
our office and talk to us which I think
was a separate experience for a lot of
people
and I still think that there was
certainly a level of you know I don't
want to say sort of like silk road level
nefarious activity but there were
certain lots of questions if not red
flag certainly strong strong yellow
flags that's turban that were raised and
frankly we were sort of caught off guard
sort of back then because we didn't
really know what kind of reception this
the market making stuff would actually
take obviously you know we didn't end up
on boarding any of these people that
sort of walked in in person but it
certainly raised the that the compliance
profile in the program as a result
absolutely well and it forces you to
address it right so there's probably
bunch of questions you hadn't been
asking then also you started asking and
then to is it probably accelerates the
build-out of your own infrastructure
right because your hey we need to get
stop people from walking in the office
with cash yeah there's no question I
think crypto security is one thing
physical security was quite another so I
think that certainly introduced a new
dimension to the way we need to kind of
think about our operations certainly
when we started doing the crypto things
very cool ok and so let's go from this
is like you know 13 or so up through 14
15 into maybe even 16 how does Genesis
kind of evolve over time right you guys
start with just Bitcoin and pretty much
just helping people buy Bitcoin right -
even today you you have a multitude of
products different assets except you're
like what does that evolution look like
so in the late summer early fall of 2013
grayscale hour assist sir as a
management company launched a big coin
of estimate trust so early on in 2013 we
were just helping to put investors into
the trust by buying the underlying
tokens and as you might imagine the
earliest investors were sort of the West
Coast of VC guys guys who understood the
risk return profile of a thousand xr0
because frankly that's what all of their
VC investment return profiles can look
like and so they were kind of the first
guys to ultimately kind of get in
obviously sort of you recall in 2013
kind of what happened to the price of
Bitcoin kind of starting the early fall
into the end of the year
and you know I think there was a lot
more media attention and sort of press
kind of started to sniff around in the
asset class when the price of Bitcoin
went from like $90 tattoo whatever 1200
1300 dollars that we gonna saw in
December early 2014 was the Mount Ox
event and I remember being in the office
we had like an emergency meeting one
Saturday and we're trying to think
through okay mal Cox just sort of
announced but their hack and and and all
of that and what are we gonna do what's
gonna happen to the price of Bitcoin and
I think all of us were like I think this
might go back to the $50 $60 price a
Bitcoin kind of before the crazy run and
we're trying to think through strategy
what can we do to kind of get out in
front of this etc and then you know it
didn't happen we didn't see the price
could have dip back down to the to the
$50 level but you know 2014-2015 there
were leaning times the institutional
interest I think that had kind of
started to look into it just entirely
kind of got on the sidelines and I
really couldn't blame them right like
you had the biggest exchange you know
was it hacked was an outside job was an
inside job how much of it was
manipulated all that kinds of things and
I think it through a lot of those into
kind of question and so you know even
into early 2015 we sort of saw the price
of Bitcoin kind of hovering around the
$200 kind of level and the lack of
volatility Bitcoin became a lot less
exciting right it came kind of boring
for for a lot of folks and you know I
think for a time a lot of the momentum
that you kind of saw in in the fall and
in winter of 2013 I think certainly
dissipated by the time early 2015 finna
came around it's interesting because you
know obviously earlier this year of 2018
we saw this big drawdown to the market
right and you know I think that there's
two camps so people say hey we're gonna
you know could fall further or we're
gonna stay kind of sideways for a while
so we will think that it's gonna reach
back by the end of the year it sounds
like during that last bear market while
the drawdown wasn't as long as you
expected it was quite you know from a
timeline perspective it did persist for
a while right and do you think there's
an element of it persisted for that long
because people had to forget about kind
of the parabolic run and the you know
following drawdown where do you think it
was more to kind of technically driven
around you know infrastructure getting
built and hash rate and things like that
I think it's it's probably a combination
of both I think when you look back to
the 2014-2015 years obviously lots of
questions around how you could even do a
fundamental analysis a Bitcoin right
there's no book value there's no
earnings how do you kind of get your
arms around it I think one of the things
that people kind of look to is where is
the infrastructure and certainly you
know while it's kind of hard to it's
probably really difficult to justify
$1,000 Bitcoin price in 2013 given the
lack of wallets and lack of any like
trading platform banking support was
kind of here nor there lots of questions
about money laundering all those types
of things I think and the price of
Bitcoin gonna clearly kind of ran ahead
of itself but I think what it kind of
forced the crypto space to do was kind
of retrenched a little bit and actually
really just build and really forget
about sort of the overnight get rich
quick type of mentality that I think a
lot of the investors may have had in
even 2013 which obviously kind of
repeated itself in 2017 but I'm sure
we'll kind of get to that later but I
think it really kind of focused the
industry to say okay there's potential
here so let's build a product let's
build the services let's kind of elevate
this thing from Bitcoin 1.0 to kind of
the next level and see where this takes
us so I think those couple years are
absolutely necessary because the price
stop being a distraction yep and it just
really focused on got your mind - sir
just focus on building the business
absolutely
and so this really takes us into like 15
and into 16 right and it goes from a
Bitcoin only world to you know aetherium
and kind of all of these all coins
ce o--'s etc from where you guys are
sitting at that point having been so
early in kind of you know building
infrastructure for Bitcoin what is that
look like what are you guys talking
about at the time what are the concerns
or are you excited about kind of these
alternative assets popping up in the
space we I think we've always imagined a
world in which multiple tokens would
certainly exist I don't really think
that any one kind of thought that
Bitcoin was kind of the one and only
and I think when when if ether sorted
came around I think initially we had a
difficult time to just kind of get her
head around what it was kind of meant to
do because I think from a design specs
perspective was just so different than
Bitcoin Bitcoin is very narrow and kind
of what its kind of meant to do whereas
if the area was exactly the opposite it
was so wide in terms of possible
applications and kind of uses via the
the smart contracts and I think and
obviously the way that ether kind of
came about and its kind of funding
mechanism was certainly interesting in
sort of the first-ever ICL right being
kind of purchased just for Bitcoin and I
think that certainly opened up eight our
minds certainly that's kind of the
possibility is what's what's possible in
a truly kind of crypto world and I think
all of the I CEOs that have sort of come
upon afterwards and kind of in the
aftermath of the ether stuff are
certainly exciting I think there's
fantastic projects I think there's a ton
of potential for for some of this stuff
on the other hand I do think that you
know that market clearly got overheated
I think the ico market there was a truly
kind of a disconnect between traditional
VC guys who said to me personally that
like these projects have a heart would
have a hard time raising a million
dollars of traditional VC funding and
they're raising 30 40 50 million dollars
in two days right there's certainly a
disconnect there or whether or not VCS
are really that bad and they're just way
too strict and kind of what they're
valuing or there's a lot of
quote-unquote dumb money kind of being
thrown at these projects and so we sit
on the sidelines there's trying to
figure out what really is happening
because it was a ton of noise certainly
last year absolutely in so that brings
me you know let's go sixteen into
seventeen and even till today an
eighteen what does the business look
like today and kind of you know what you
offer to clients across you know your
different lines of business so we'll
just touch on our Genesis trading to
kind of start with from an
infrastructure perspective we're now
market making eight or nine different
tokens and our decision to sort of add
tokens are entirely based on investor
demand so we're institutions only our
average trade size is somewhere between
half a million to a million dollars
right now and so unlike kind of the
exchanges that do thousands and
thousands of transactions we're much
more kind of smaller in terms of trades
per day but we're you know doing
anywhere from call it half a billion to
like two billion dollars a month I'm in
terms of total OTC volume it's still
mostly Bitcoin I'll probably say 75% of
our volume is kind of Bitcoin right now
number two kind of varies kind of
month-to-month XRP hue january as you
might possibly imagine so they kind of
occupied the number two spot but it kind
of switches but most months is probably
still still ether is probably probably
gas but we offer just a two-sided market
and we just recently hired an overnight
trader to kind of cover asia hours so we
have a guy that sort of doing that at
2:00 3:00 4:00 in the morning which sort
of introduced sort of a new market for
us um so I think that's been a really
sort of interesting kind of addition to
our service and then in February we
launched Genesis Capital which is our
lending business we've had sort of small
pockets of demand for for crypto borrow
over the years and we've always kind of
run it out of our broker dealer taking
some of the bitcoins and ether that we
owned on our balance sheet and kind of
lending them
out we realized that this was a true
kind of opportunity because one I think
it's really important for the market
growth to have a two-sided price
discovery possible in a long only market
I just didn't see this sort of the
institutional money being able to kind
of come in if the only thing you can do
is just buy and then we also said hey
you know it's a fantastic sort of
hedging tool for investors they may own
crypto l-square that want to take a
short position and kind of hedge your
exposure at one point without selling
their initial purchases - I think the
growth in the futures market has sort of
seen futures market makers come to
Genesis capital to get a borrow on the
spot market because as they're taking
action on the futures side they're able
to hedge instantly on the spot market
via a borrow and then we've had guys who
just wanted the outright short it that
had no long position that we're happy to
sort of take a calculated naked short
bet that either this thing is zero or
close to zero and that over time this
thing will actually play itself out we
launched the business with about 20
million in loans in February and I think
right now we're about a hundred and
twenty five million dollars or so in
sort of our overall loan portfolio and I
think we've originated about a quarter
billion of loans so far so demand is
there and the fantastic part about it is
that we're really only lending to the
best of the best
again we're not facing individuals these
are all hedge funds and certain
institutional accounts we're doing the
credit work plus they're posting US
dollar collateral against kind of loan
positions were making so it's been a
fantastic sort of new service addition
for us and it allows both sides bulls
and bears to actually put on a position
in the in the spot market absolutely no
it's fascinating - to go from 20 million
to about 125 today at the 250 million
dollars or so in kind of total loans is
this all in Bitcoin and Bitcoin and
ether what's the kind of disparity look
like given what you see on the OTC side
right it's similar it's it's interesting
we get fantastic on a market color so
we've seen in 2018 so far sort of price
resistance in Bitcoin in the high fives
some around the 5,800 level so we've had
guys who initiated short positions kind
of in the 7,000 area and then for you
know because they feel some level of
resistance on the price close out their
shorts somewhere around the six thousand
fifty nine hundred number
we've had guys kind of do a rinse and
repeat have the price kind of come up to
the seven thousand submission to short
right back down but that's why they
close and so when folks kind of talk
about hey I think we've seen the lows of
the year kind of come in it's actually
playing out that way in the loan market
because no one keeps their loans
outstanding for very long once we kind
of hit the high fives ether there really
isn't a bottom I don't have that
sentiment for ether and that's just kind
of the way data is kind of playing
itself out and we don't have guys that
try to play the you know I think there's
resistance around the you know the 275
level and so those short they're way
down from 300 down to 75 I think there's
plenty of people that kind of keep their
loans outstanding on the a theorem for
for a lot longer than that and that's
actually playing out on the on the OTC
side to last two weeks prior to this run
right now into the mid 7,000 we couldn't
find a Bitcoin seller in the low six
thousands we've had some buyers about
very very few sellers there was no
shortage or theorem sellers no no we
could have sourced a ton of ethereum if
there was by side demand enough the time
to get that done right so people talk
about price decoupling and Bitcoin and
ether which kind of created on paths
with each other for for quite some time
I think we've already kind of started to
see that yeah that's super fascinating
in it so if you started the business in
February this is kind of initial
drawdown had already been initiated
right how much of the shorting that
happened maybe December January time
frame was volume that you saw and that
drove the decision to get into the
lending side or you were already kind of
planning I do
and then you know the timing just works
given the market conditions I wish I was
smart enough to kind of predict it you
know in December and January this is the
way we play out but we really this made
the decision about a over a year ago now
this is an early 2016 where we said how
a 20-17 rather why we decided to launch
Genesis Capital it's an idea that we
didn't kicking around kind of internal
and said hey one day is gonna be kind of
the right time to do it and myself and
the board kind of decided that early
2017 was kind of the year in which we're
gonna try this and it obviously took you
know six or nine months they're gonna
hire some folks and kind of build the
infrastructure and kind of plan the
launch of the business but but yeah that
February just happened to be when we
were ready to go that's awesome okay so
obviously you guys are you know very
well versed in kind of liquid Cryptozoic
cryptocurrencies and really kind of
participate in maybe the top 10 or so
kind of liquid Kryptos one of the things
that a lot of people been talking about
is tokenized securities right so kind of
these these tokens that are backed by
stocks bonds you know currency or
commodities etc and so one of the show
sponsors is a block estate price Ibaka
stay calm and they've basically created
this equity token for real estate right
so but for sure we're talking that you
just bought a home yes and so the
thought process would be rather than you
signing off the paperwork etc you could
actually own a token that represented
ownership in your home right hmm how do
you guys look at you know these equity
tokens or these asset backed tokens in
light of your business and then the
overall ecosystem I think one of the
things that we are still trying to kind
of figure out is if these are
technically securities and if they are
then they would be obviously under sort
of SEC FINRA oversight and kind of
purview and I think there's a lot of
questions and guys the kind of needs to
be put out by both regulators about how
we should think about trading these
assets
how gonna be the custodian of these
assets right the the traditional crypto
guys are not are not qualified to be
securities custodians so that's when you
know Northern Trust is building
something it's possible that Goldman
Sachs is gonna build something there's
kind of been rumors in the press about
both of these guys and it's kind of
getting the traditional securities
custodians in place I think is a key key
determinant of how it happened now
personally on the tokenize real estate
front yes I did just buy a house last
week it was a painful process in terms
of the closing it took about an hour and
a half of just signing my life away hit
this entire process have been a lot more
seamless by having real estate on the
blockchain a hundred percent and the
deed just kind of is on the blockchain
it's sort of provable and when it's time
to sell the house
I just transfer the lead assets over to
another address I think there's a lot of
um efficiencies that can come about but
I think it really kind of depends on
whether regulators kind of sit on this
absolutely and it's interesting too
because if all of a sudden you get these
asset backed tokens right when it
whether it's OTC trading lending etc it
opens up a world of possibility
Regan's today you're basically doing
this with you know Bitcoin for example a
digital currency right but imagine if
you could do with every asset class
alright so so it's fascinating to think
about and you know for those I want to
learn more about block estate ago block
estate calm but okay so let's talk about
the broader ecosystem for a second right
what is the part of crypto that you find
most fascinating or interesting that
most people don't talk about I think one
of the things that I try to find really
reclined of interesting is how everyone
and I don't blame them for doing this
but I think everyone is trying to fit it
coin blockchain crypto into an existing
bucket in terms of the way they kind of
analyze prices and for structure
fundamentals that type of stuff and and
I think we're really still trying to get
our arms around how do you value this
stuff and while there's plenty of kind
of theories and kind of valuation
thought pieces kind of around the asset
class I still think the
the Equity Research equivalent of crypto
is still sort of a work in progress I am
sure over time there will be sort of an
investment banks that dedicated entire
equity research coverage teams to this
space and tried to come up with an
industry consensus for how we kind of
think about this stuff but you know
that's that's still up in the air and
lots of competing thoughts about how to
kind of do this and but my hope is at
some point the industry can come
together and come up with a DCF or a
market comparables or any of those types
of things to kind of think about the
right way to think about it then it's
easier to kind of get your head around
like price targets whether they actually
mean anything or not but I do think that
traditional investors will look to
equity research equivalent sort of in
the crypto space as they kind of make
their investment decisions yeah and a
lot of it is I think one there's got to
be some level of standardization right
when it comes to hey these are the
things that we're actually gonna look at
from a data perspective and then to is
the way that everyone interprets that
interprets that data right so you and I
may look at you know for example a
revenue multiple in the public markets
and we may think that the company's
actually worth different things but at
least we agree that that is one of the
data points that are important to
valuing a company I think I think that's
right I think and there's certainly
plenty of calm controversy around just
data generally and the integrity of the
data you know while I have no doubt that
like 2017-2018 blockchain data in
Bitcoin people can kind of come to a
consensus around what the right data is
go back to 2012 good luck trying to get
actual real data on Bitcoin back then or
even trying to figure out the hash rates
of litecoin from just a couple years ago
those data is really kind of hard to
come by and while I do think there's
kind of promising data projects I think
there's still a lot of work to be done
on data curation side before we even get
to trying to figure out the right
methods of valuation that the industry
can kind of rally around absolutely I
mean look one of the things that
happened I think it was either end of
last year beginning of this year that
just reading it that much attention was
when coin market caps switched up some
of the data sources it was pulling in
and all of a sudden white like a hundred
billion dollars of market cap right and
that was one of the kind of higher
quality reference data sources and so
you know that immediately pulls into
question what is the quality of the data
that they're using and the data that
they're presenting to people and so I
think that that's just one website right
you across exchange of the data
providers etc this is a huge issue and
again I don't know if we're really gonna
get to a solution right in the short
term but I do think that getting to a
point where there's audits or validation
of data and kind of consistency and
accuracy is essential to get these
institutional investors in I think
that's right and and this is like the
unsexy stuff right this is the back
office accounting finance operations
work but that's really kind of what's
necessary to kind of move the you know
spot forward and frankly there really
shouldn't be like ads of let's say
midnight at 12:31 what was the price of
Bitcoin right and I guarantee you the
file of the people in this room will
come up with different prices because
you reference different exchanges or
different indices and we really haven't
agreed upon kind of the standard now
there are folks that's trying to kind of
raise their hand and kind of become that
certainly the efforts that the CM e has
done for instance around the Bitcoin
reference rate as they priced their
futures the CBOE obviously has something
kinda similar is a way to kind of get
there but I do think that industry
consensus I think is yet to be seen
absolutely so actually let's dive in a
little bit how you guys use data on the
OTC side so first of all there's my
plenty of people who are listening who
actually don't even understand what OTC
trading is so maybe kind of give you no
quick two minute overview of what is OTC
trading that we take how you guys use
data sure
so OTC trading is all post trade
settlement so as opposed to exchanges
where you pre fund the exchanges with
either Fiat dollars or Bitcoin or ether
or like coin whatever it is we actually
agree to a transaction first this is the
way all Wall Street sort of works and
that you agree to the transaction first
an old Wall Street also trades and does
settlements t plus two so trade date
plus two days
so on the third day is when you actually
settle the transaction encrypt out
things move a lot faster and so we're
much more sort of same-day settled so
we're much more like T plus an hour or
two hours kind of opposed to settlement
but we agree in the trade at the time we
agree on the trade that trade is
actually agree it's regardless of what
happens to the price up or down we honor
the trade and we expect all of our
counterparties to do the same if you're
selling you Bitcoin we give you a bank
wiring instructions you send the bank
wire a bank money to us and then we just
send you the bitcoins to your address
and certifies first it's a very simple
kind of straightforward process but it's
much easier than trying to wait for the
wire to to hit any of the exchanges
before you put on the trade in part of
this is so the way that it works in
practice right is I can call you I can
message you you know whatever way I
choose to communicate and I talk to
somebody who works at Genesis and we
come to an agreement I literally say hey
I want to buy you know five Bitcoin and
so many other sites is okay we'll sell
you find Bitcoin at X price right once
we actually agree that is where the
trade is final in terms of you know
price amount et cetera
hmmm and then the settlement is actually
what you just described in terms of the
the transaction of Thea or crypto
trading hands correct the exchange is
the settlement portion but that comes
after we agree upon the transaction yep
and the reason why somebody does this
right one is either they want to get
lower fees right than going on an
exchange with a large transaction two is
they want to guarantee that there is
some liquidity there right and kind of
consummate the trade much faster are
there other reasons why somebody's doing
that or those the two main things I
think the certainly the two that you
mentioned exchange slippage is certainly
one thing and we're much tighter
probably on a spread on a five million
dollar transaction say than than some of
the exchanges the other thing that feet
pokes folks like the face Genesis is
kind of our highly regulated status for
the institutional guys and they're they
have limited partner investors who rely
on the general partner
they don't want any questions as to
where do these bitcoins come from how do
I know that a Silk Road guy didn't own
these bitcoins three hops ago so the
trust they are AML kyc compliance
process to kind of know that these
bitcoins were that we're vouching for
them and that questions around hey where
did you get these bitcoins from from
your auditor or your compliance
department oh we got these from a broker
dealer it kind of ends the conversation
kind of at that point and so provenance
of bitcoins and it's kind of the crypto
is certainly one of the value-add of
sort of facing an OTC desk makes sense
okay and so obviously if I'm somebody
who wants to purchase via OTC and I call
you guys up how do you determine that
price right so we're talking you know we
talked a little bit about kind of the
quality of data that's out there are you
guys going to one exchange kind of
taking a you know average of a couple of
exchanges how do you actually use that
data to kind of get confidence around
this is the price that we're comfortable
trading it so our early technology
partners a company called trade block
and trade block kind of helps power our
trading platform at Genesis and they
have an index called the xbx which takes
into account they volume weighted
average price across some of the biggest
US dollar exchanges and so our quotes
are based off the xbx we don't try to
rely on sort of any single exchange
because as you might imagine you know
this is kind of less the case now but a
year ago two years ago certainly prices
vary greatly kind of across exchanges if
you only looked at kind of one exchange
for for from market color you would have
been off kind of what market was and so
the I think the advent of a lot more
sort of market makers and some of the
high-frequency guys kind of get involved
I've sort of removed exchange ARB
opportunities and so prices are trading
way more uniform across exchanges than
they were in the past but we do rely on
an index from from trade block as far as
how we think about kind of auto quoting
got it yeah in exchange our was huge and
even as early as or as late as last year
right I mean I mean there's people who
are literally setting that up as their
trading shed that's 100% correct but
like I said I think all of that is is
gone by now got it
okay ensue
as we look forward right what do you
think are the areas that people are not
building in that are going to be either
important or are gonna become kind of
the focal point as we you know kind of
go into early nineteen and maybe even to
2020 ultimately I think there are
questions around the exchange
infrastructure and how that kind of
ultimately develops over time today you
have in the traditional markets you have
sort of the Nasdaq New York Stock
Exchange which is the pure matching
engine but they actually don't hold any
equities or any money they're just
matching buyers and sellers right and
then you have the DTC that kind of does
the settlement aspect of it and then
there's a separate custodian right state
streets and the BNY Mellon z-- that are
actually holding the the securities they
actually have three different parties in
the traditional world whereas all three
happens by the same company in crypto
today you find coinbase they hold your
coins that hold your fiat and there's
also the matching engine and they're
also the settlement agent so you
basically have pockets of funds kind of
globally kind of scattered is that
really the way that this base ultimately
kind of evolves it's possible or will
the New York Stock Exchange kind of
model well a DTC get created at some
point to kind of help settle
transactions cuz I think one of the
things in the OTC space is somebody
still has to act first there isn't this
concept of simultaneous settlement and
EVP delivery versus payment that you see
in this world and traditional investors
really aren't interested obviously kind
of taking that counterparty risk right
what if I send the money and you don't
send me the bitcoins then what happens
to me and while that's why you work with
reputable counterparties on the OTC side
I think a lot of that concern can be
alleviated if you actually create a sort
of a DTC for crypto but there has to be
so trustworthy so well-funded and it's
possible but I think it'll take a lot of
effort to kind of get there amid only
get built by a
financial like incumbent um if you
recall I think the DTC was initially
funded by the big banks right and so
certainly getting industry participants
that kind of help fund a group effort
certainly goes a long way because you
immediate you have immediate buy-in from
the incumbent participants to it's sort
of a DTC is it possible that the
existing crypto guys can put funds
together certainly but if we're really
targeting the the biggest hedge funds
and family offices in the world
I'm a little bit skeptical that they
trust and effort put together by a bunch
of startups I think they want to see
some traditional money kind of backing
it to really give them the comfort level
that everything's on the up-and-up
yeah locally it's something that we talk
all the time right it's to an extent
Wall Street is the best thing that could
happen to crypto and on the on the flip
side it's the worst thing that could
happen to crack down right in terms of
Catelyn long came on and she's talking
about you know kind of the
rehypothecation of Bitcoin and and you
know really attacking the core value
prop of this scarce asset Wall Street
doesn't really like scarce assets right
and so I think that it's you know a
double-edged sword there I think that's
probably right but I think you know I
would argue most if not everyone wants
to see the price of Bitcoin going up to
100k half a million a million dollars
and I'm strongly of the belief that this
doesn't happen with that Wall Street
involvement mm-hmm it makes sense okay
you said earlier was at Genesis you guys
just brought on kind of the first
overnight trader right and so obviously
you're doing that to address or serve
this global community right in the
customers that you guys have coming to
you either on the OTC side or on the
lending side talk about kind of the the
demographics right these are obviously
kind of higher quality either borrowers
or
participants but mostly domestic focus
internationally even what what does that
really look like I would say that today
we're still about seventy-five percent
domestic here in the US but it's our
international counterparties that are
growing the fastest so over time I do
expect the ratio to get closer to 5050
if not flip upside down entirely but
like I said I think a lot of the Asia
flow and kind of the conversations that
sort of happen we're just kind of
scratching the surface so I think that's
an exciting kind of growth opportunity
for us the one thing we haven't done is
open up foreign offices we've decided to
go 24/7 out of New York for now what
we're really kind of realizing is that a
lot of the liquidity is sort of isolated
in separate countries especially in Asia
like there's a Tokyo market a separate
Hong Kong market there's a separate
market in South Korea separate mark in a
bunch of different countries and there's
really kind of isn't fantastic kind of
overlap across the countries and so you
have really siloed pockets of liquidity
and trying to figure out which country
to set up an office and figure out what
their laws and regulations as well just
hiring kind of the upstart cost we
really couldn't justify that right so
what we're doing for now is trying to
figure out where the liquidity is where
the interest is I gather the data
ourselves out of New York and then we're
in a much better position to kind of
decide what to do once we figure out
what the right you know right right
market for that is but you know at the
end of the day everyone's trading on an
email or via screen they don't really
care where the traders are sitting right
and so we really haven't had pushback as
far as from folks and say hey you don't
actually physically have a trader in
Tokyo that doesn't really seem to matter
absolutely it's funny to talk about
trading over email or screens obviously
on Wall Street that's not how it's done
right and somebody said to me the other
day that Skype right is like the OTC
backbone of the entire crypto industry
because there's so much done via
messaging and video etc and so it's just
fascinating
you know the infrastructures not to the
level yet of Wall Street but given that
were you know 10 years less into this
actually quite bit of infrastructure
that's been built
of sits here today to allow you to you
know operate on a global scale all from
New York City right with a number of
different assets and both on the OTC and
the lending side what I think is also
interesting I think is that like you
have to remember like as as a broker
deal that we've been doing traditional
securities for years before we got
involved in crypto we know how everyone
all the traders on Wall Street used the
bloomberg chat function right and so a
plenty of trades get agreed upon in
Bloomberg chat then you just cut tickets
on Bloomberg to sort of make it formal a
lot of the negotiation kind of the
bathroom for still happen over chat it's
just setting crypto we don't have sort
of the the active community on Bloomberg
yet I bet that's coming and really like
whoever controls the chat really
controls the audience right and so we
kid around from time to time that
somebody like Skype should just open up
a crypto trading platform and you
already own the conversation and I do
think that's a large part of actually
who gets the transactions yeah it's
fascinating all right so let's talk
about a couple of the controversial
things that are going on in crypto right
now and kind of from your seat what you
guys think so tether huge kind of you
know back and forth as to whether
actually are back to one to one the US
dollar or not kind of what is your guys
take her or even you personally in terms
of how you see that playing out any
concerns there obviously I think that
the industry as a whole has a lot of
vested interest in making sure tether
has is fully kind of collateralized on
US dollar and I don't really I don't
have a view one way the other if it is
or not but it has certainly spawned a
whole host of other kind of stable coins
and kind of currencies out there that I
think tether was first to market and I
don't know whether other guys would have
really jumped in
if tether could have been way more kind
of transparent about their books and
records I think that would have been
that might have been like a closed door
to a lot of these companies but
questions and skepticism kind of around
tether gave the opportunity for a lot of
these guys to kind of launch their own
thing I certainly think it's interesting
but I've always said to my traders I
don't want you guys trading 35 stable
coins right
there needs to be more of an industry
consensus around one two tokens maximum
and as these projects kind of come on
board and come online is actually start
trading I'm sure it'll be like a market
test whoever strong enough and has the
most liquidity will end up winning and
kind of play itself out I think there's
a lot of interesting things about the
traditional asset back model versus some
of the algorithmic models that's kind of
out there and and kind of made them best
one win but ultimately it's all about
confidence and whether or not the market
really believes in the product that
you're selling but that's no different
than like crypto and people kind of
buying into the vision white paper what
it's ultimately trying to do I don't
think it's any different on the stable
coin side absolutely no I completely
agree obviously some of the people who
are transacting in thether specifically
are the retail right investors who are
trying to go in and out of crypto or
kind of transact with with some level of
safety in terms of that value one of the
things that I think people are really
pushing for is the participation of
retail investors into just investing in
general right so solves with the ico
boom where all these non-accredited
investors could start to participate
remains to be seen kind of how
regulators will come down in terms of
was that stuff compliant or not but
recently the SEC chairman said you know
they're looking at ways to get the
non-accredited investors into more
private type opportunities in a
compliant way but still provide the
investor protection train you guys are
obviously dealing with much more
institutional type investors is it a
thing where if there was the regulatory
compliance and protections available you
think that you'd be able to kind of go
down funnel and start to you know
interface with more of those retail type
investors or is it something where just
from a ticket size etc it's kind of you
know preventing you from going down it's
it's certainly much more the latter
we're just not set up from us systems
operational infrastructure to be
onboarding like thousands and thousands
of counterparties we're much more sort
of high-touch white-glove service and it
would be really difficult for Genesis I
think to offer the same high quality
customers
servus if we had like a hundred thousand
users kind of calling in kind of at the
same time to be able to speak to Genesis
representative and so it's much less
about you know the accredited investor
kind of definition around like
suitability for instance then it is much
more about hey that's a market that the
exchanges service very very well but
it's kind of the the bigger ticket guys
are the ones where it's worth it from a
customer acquisition costs perspective
to spend the time effort to get on the
phone on board educate because the
l'aventure kind of trade through us got
it okay and then what about the kind of
legacy tech buyers right so you've got
the Facebook's Google's Twitter's of the
world how do you see them playing into
this right so Facebook's got their
blockchain team they're kind of going
after I don't think Google's really said
too much other than they're gonna ban
some you know crypto ads Twitter same
thing like how do you see an audience in
a crypto space who comes out of that
tech industry for the most part
interfacing back with those you know
tech incumbents my hope is that um the
solution for any of these incumbents is
not to create their own token and you
know they just hop on the backs of the
Bitcoin or ether or like pick one of the
existing ones and not kind of create
like Facebook dollars right on the
Facebook coin but you sort of seen the
way that that Square has sort of
integrated kind of Bitcoin into their
payments platform I do think that the
rather than kind of quite you know
creating square coin they kind of went
with with Bitcoin is kind of the future
Internet money in the way that Jack
Dorsey is currently kind of thinking
about it and so I do hope that they
figure out ways to reward content
creators by letting them hate accept
payments and whatever cryptocurrency of
your choosing without kind of creating
the additional friction of a Twitter
coin and having to make people sort of
by whatever that token is because
chances are that author is not holding
on to the Twitter coin they're gonna
turn right around
at 4-4 Fiat absolutely it is Facebook
specifically I have continued to say one
of the greatest things that could happen
to crypto is if Facebook gave everyone a
digital wallet and somehow drove
adoption of Bitcoin
right yeah I think that just the
inflection point of 2000 2 billion plus
people getting to interface with this
digital currency you know would be like
nothing we've ever seen i under percent
agree and i think that if you rewarded
users who click on banners by giving you
a little bit of Bitcoin in your facebook
wallet just give it even without having
to buy anything right I think just
owning some gives you that incentive and
kind of the interest to follow it more
and I do think there's a lot of creative
ways to I think get more adoption
certainly at the consumer mass level
simply by rewarding folks back in the in
crypto yeah it's awesome alright so I
got one more question for you and then I
let every guess ask me a question so so
so think of a good one there what is the
one thing in crypto that you believe
that you think a majority of the people
you know would disagree with you on that
is a good question I'll have to think
about this one for a few seconds while I
also simultaneously come up with a
question for you the big intelligence
test on this podcast I think that the US
will get their head around AI cos and
that they I will say that within 10
years the US will not be the kind of the
ostracised ICL market that it exists
today I do believe that regulators while
they certainly are scared
first and foremost will get their head
around the fact that if they don't adopt
all of that capital formation and
capital funding moves offshore I don't
think that's in the best interest of the
United States that kind of let that
happen
I do think that the u.s. continued needs
to continue to be a hotbed for for
startups and kind of fund funding and I
do think that they'll get their head
around icos and that US will be a hotbed
for I SEOs within 10 years yeah I mean
look I I completely agree with you right
I actually think that I SEOs are just a
different name for an IPO right so it's
a funding mechanism our capital
formation event and the only reason why
it is different is because the current
laws force it to be mmhmm right but if
we change the laws then they would look
very similar right you could see a world
where they say look you've got to report
X information you've got to have these
disclosures you can only raise capital
from you know one group of people versus
another I mean it really is kind of
taking the Wild West and just putting a
box around it and saying you know here's
the right way to do this stuff mm-hmm
right not very very cool all right
what a what question do you have for me
all right in the last 30 seconds I've
come up with one is so ether is two
hundred and seventy-five dollars today
is ether more likely to be a thousand
dollars or ten dollars so everyone who's
ever come on here always asked me like
random questions about Twitter etc and
you asked me about price is amazing so
I'm one of these folks who when it comes
to ether I do not think that it's very
analogous to Bitcoin right in terms of
the deflation airy schedule versus
inflationary and kind of the way that
it's used as utility I probably want the
confidence to say that it's going to $10
right but I do think that the mechanism
in which it is used
especially that decoupling that you
talked about of prices it is much more
likely to stay depressed according to
where Bitcoin goes right and then the
thought process there is you are
incentivized to use what you are holding
if you want to use the network right and
so you know kind of the macro economics
of that forces a lot more downward
pressure than say Bitcoin where because
of the deflation and
ultimately the detraction of the month
of the monetary supply people are
incentivized to hold right and so it is
you know the decoupling piece is really
interesting to me because at the core
there are two separate systems in terms
of how the assets are both created held
and ultimately incentivize to use or not
use and so I think that you know it's
much more likely to do lower than it is
to go higher right over a long period of
time great awesome and I really
appreciate the time this is this is
fascinating I think that a lot of people
gonna get a lot out of the OTC trading
and kind of what you guys do so I
appreciate coming on thanks for having
me